jamie dimon was at a finance conference
on wednesday and he had some choice
words for investors in the audience he
thinks that there's a financial storm
coming and i think jamie dimon is
talking about some stuff that you should
be paying attention to he said that you
need to brace yourself for an economic
hurricane caused by the fed in the
ukraine war now of course this was a
very long conversation so here's a
couple of the top quotes that i thought
you should pay attention to the first is
he says you know i said previously that
there's storm clouds but i'm going to
change it it's a hurricane wall
conditions seem fine at the moment
nobody knows if a hurricane is a minor
one or super storm sandy he then went on
to say you better brace yourself jp
morgan is bracing ourselves and we're
going to be very conservative with our
balance sheet then next right now it's
kind of sunny things are doing fine
everyone thinks the fed can handle this
that hurricane is right out there down
the road and it's coming our way we've
never had quantitative tightening like
this so you're looking at something you
could be writing history books on for 50
years several aspects of qe backfired
including negative rates which he thinks
was a huge mistake and then lastly he
stated that wars go bad they go south
and unintended consequences that the
united states and the rest of the global
audience is not taking the proper
actions to protect europe from what's
going to happen to oil in the short run
now of course jamie dimon is highly
intelligent he runs one of the largest
banks in the world and he's got more
information and data at his fingertips
than almost anyone else that i know and
so naturally when he says that there's a
financial storm coming you should pay
attention and when he says don't listen
to what we're saying watch what we're
doing we're going to be conservative
with our balance sheet you should start
paying attention nobody knows the future
nobody has a crystal ball how bad will
the recession be will we get a recession
nobody knows but what we do know is that
we've been in a quantitative easing a
loose monetary policy for the last 13
years or so there was one bout where
they tried to do some quantitative
tightening and they basically gave up
almost immediately because it didn't
work and so naturally the big question
here is how committed will the federal
reserve be as they've talked tough as
they've raised interest rates and now as
they're actually conducting quantitative
tightening asset prices are falling
stocks bonds real estate crypto
everything is down how bad can it get no
one actually knows but what i think that
most people who understand finance who
understand markets and who have lived
through many market cycles before
there's one thing that they all agree on
you gotta make sure that you survive
they shore up their balance sheets
either personally or professionally they
make sure that they have cash that they
can weather the storm because one of the
big things in finances if you don't make
it to the other side you don't get to
live to play anymore and so naturally
making sure that you've got a strong
balance sheet one that can survive the
economic hurricane is going to be highly
important do what you need to do to make
sure that you could last 12 18 24 months
nobody knows how long it'll last nobody
knows how bad it'll get but one thing is
sure you've got liquidity and you've got
a strong balance sheet you got a good
shot of actually getting to the other
side of this hey you did you like this
video great we make five of them a day
and post them here on this channel make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time